this morning hollywood is remembering
olivia de havilland one of the last
stars from cinema's so-called
golden age the oscar-winning actress
died at her home in paris yesterday at
the age of 104.
she appeared in dozens of films in her
decades-long career including
of course gone with the wind off screen
she was called a fighter
who challenged hollywood's contract
system
his house won't see the same without
it's the role for which she was
most famous playing melanie in the 1939
classic film
gone with the win
it also scored olivia de havilland her
first of five
academy award nominations she would go
on to win
two the first for playing an unwed
mother
in 1946's to each his own
and again in 1950 for her lead role in
the heiress
he finds me pleasing oh yes i'm sure he
does
thank you for this very generous
assurance
she returned to the oscar stage over a
half century later
as a presenter at the 2003 oscars
this night is a memorable one for me
and so was that night 53 years ago
never a pushover de havilland pushed for
fully
realized characters and famously took on
the studio system
fighting and winning in court to get out
of her restrictive contract to warner
brothers
a contract first signed when she was
just 18
years old but had her playing opposite
errol flynn
in the adventures of robin hood robin
and you do love me don't you she would
go on to star in movies for the next
55 years retiring from film
in 1988. she moved to television winning
a golden globe for her work in anastasia
the mystery of anna she first won the
award
in 1950. my golden globe back home has
been waiting
i think it's 37 years for a mate
and at last i can take this companion
back
one of the last stars of the golden age
of hollywood
olivia de havilland gone at the age of
104.
what an extraordinary life she lived
gail you know she made
eight films with errol flynn they each
had crushes on the other although
nothing ever happened jimmy stewart
didn't propose to her she said she
wasn't ready
the man she wanted to marry was john
huston but that didn't happen
and that law that the contract that she
broke
ended up changing hollywood forever she
was actually blacklisted for about two
years because of it
but that law that now limits contracts
is called the de havilland law
still wow
what a life she led anthony 104
also like regis dying in her sleep at
natural causes
wow she was a treasure to all of us